Back in the late 19th and early 20th centuries
as food began to be more and more mass produced
and shipped long distances, instead of locally
grown and sold fresh, it was basically the
Wild West in regards to food production and
there were no real official regulations on
what you could add to food, or even that if
you labeled something chicken, that it had
to contain any chicken at all.
And as there were also no rules about reporting
any ingredients, businesses pretty much did
whatever they pleased.
To give you an idea of the kind of stuff the
food and drug industries were cramming into
things, secretly adding morphine to children’s
cough syrup was a thing and, more pertinent
to the subject at hand today, commonly used
preservatives back then included borax, formaldehyde,
sulfuric acid, and copper sulfate, just to
name a few.
It also wasn’t uncommon to use lead for
coloring candy or to do things like grind
up various organs and scraps from animals
and sell it as chicken meat; grind up white
rocks and clay to fill out flour; and use
sawdust, charcoal and ground up charred animal
bones to fill out coffee grounds.
As an example of how widespread selling a
product as one thing when it was actually
something else was, in one experiment conducted
by our hero of the hour, Dr. Harvey Wiley,
his team found that 9 out of the 10 maple
syrup brands sold in Indiana did not actually
include any maple syrup in their supposedly
pure maple syrup product.
By the turn of the century, the state of the
food industry had become a major cause for
concern in terms of public health, but nobody
was bothering to do anything about.
Enter Dr. Wiley and his Hygenic Table Trials.
The experiments were designed to test the
safety of various preservatives commonly used
by the food industry at the time.
Although they began in 1902, Dr. Wiley had
been petitioning the government to conduct
such experiments for a couple decades (reportedly
from almost the moment he scored the gig of
chief chemist at the Department of Agriculture
in 1883), only to be rebuffed by his bosses
when food industry lobbyists caught wind of
what he was up to.
Finally in 1902 though, Wiley was given $5,000
(about $143,000 today) and permission to do
whatever was necessary to test the safety
of various food preservatives.
Permission in hand, he set about finding 12
volunteers for a series of experiments the
media would come to dub “The Poison Squad
Trials”.
While you might think finding volunteers to
potentially ingest something harmful to the
human body would be difficult, Dr. Wiley would
later note that he was inundated with requests
from men (women weren’t allowed to take
part in the experiment) wanting to join.
For example, in one letter, the individual
in question wrote,
Dear Sir,
I read in the paper of your experiments on
diet.
I have a stomach can stand anything.
I have a stomach that will surprise you.
I am afflicted with 7 diseases.
Never went to a doctor for 15 years.
They told me 15 years age that I could not
live 8 months.
What do you think of it?
My stomach can hold anything…
Of course, it helped that Wiley was also offering
a bit of pay for the gig and providing free
lodging and prepared meals for a minimum of
six months, with the person otherwise being
able to go about their regular lives at normal
jobs and the like.
Owing to the nature of the experiment, volunteers
were expected to be in perfect health and
during their time taking part were given the
best medical care money could provide.
In return, all the volunteers had to do was
eat whatever Wiley put in front of them and
agree not to sue him or the government if
they suffered serious complications.
The general method used to ensure safety and
figure out if the doses in common product
were bad was to start with ultra low doses
and slowly ramp up over time until the subjects
started having adverse effects, if any.
As for the experiments themselves, they began
by establishing a baseline for vitals on each
subject over the course of weeks and then
the fun began, starting with borax which was
commonly used to preserve meat at the time.
Initially the plan was to add the borax to
the food, but Wiley quickly noticed that as
the dosage ramped up volunteers started avoiding
anything the borax was added to due to its
strong, metallic taste.
Thus, he simply began giving volunteers a
capsule full of borax at the end of each meal
instead.
To keep track of any and all effects the borax
had on the volunteers, their vital signs were
carefully measured several times a day and
they were forbidden from eating any outside
food so as to not contaminate the findings.
Each man’s poop and pee was also analysed
extensively and every volunteer was given
a medical satchel containing various vials
and containers they were asked to do their
business into during their day-to-day lives
away from the house the experiment was taking
place in.
The effects of the borax were noticed within
weeks, with volunteers complaining of everything
from headaches to depression and symptoms
getting more and more severe as time went
on.
That said, for the most part volunteers, who
were occasionally rotated out when transitioning
to a new substance to minimize the chances
of long term health problems, remained in
good spirits for the five years the experiments
took place.
Notable exceptions to this were a few months
into the borax experiments where volunteers
briefly went on strike due to the symptoms
becoming severe, as well as during trials
involving formaldehyde.
At the time this was commonly used as a preservative
in various dairy products, but caused such
debilitating illness in volunteers almost
right away that Wiley cut the experiment short
out of concern for their safety.
Other than this, the group that the media
would come to dub The Poison Squad seemed
to enjoy the experiments and some of the things
tested didn’t have any apparent adverse
effects, like sodium benzoate, making for
a rather pleasant few months for that set
of volunteers.
To add a touch of class to the proceedings,
volunteers would dress in formal attire for
evening meals, which, in addition to making
these meals seem fancy, made for excellent
publicity shots- shots which appeared in papers
across the country alongside stories discussing
the details of the experiments.
These stories were immensely popular with
the public, particularly when the substances
were causing ill effects.
The food industry, however, were less enthusiastic
with the findings, which showed a lot of the
then common preservatives were really bad
for you.
Thus, they used their collective might and
political sway to suppress papers Wiley wrote
on the experiments.
These efforts were ultimately fruitless, however,
as Wiley saw to it that his reports got leaked
to the press anyway.
When efforts to block the release of his findings
failed, various industry insiders took to
attacking Wiley’s credibility instead, as
well as spouting rhetoric like claiming he
was a “man who is doing all he can to destroy
American business” and the like.
In the end, the mob was roused thanks to the
expirements, spearheaded by Women’s Clubs
across the country who tirelessly lobbied
for what would become the 1906 Pure Food and
Drug Act, aptly nicknamed The Wiley Act.
This Act, among other things, put in place
rules requiring listing ingredients on labels
so consumers could know, at least to some
extent, what they were actually getting.
The idea at this point was not so much to
regulate the industries directly, but rather
increase transparency so the consumers could
decide whether they wanted to drink something
that used formaldehyde as a preservative,
for example.
This Act, however, still left an amazing amount
of wiggle room for various companies to exploit,
culminating in the infamous Elixir Sulfanilamide
Incident that condemned over 107 people (most
of whom were children) to a slow and excruciating
death thanks to the company involved adding
a known highly poisonous compound to their
product simply because it helped the main
ingredient dissolve well in the mixture…
Even when the death count started rolling
in almost immediately, the company still only
sent a telegram to doctors telling them to
return the product, but didn’t bother telling
them why or express the seriousness of the
issue, so many ignored the telegram and continued
to accidentally kill their patients.
More on this shortly in the Bonus Fact below.
Going back to the Poison Squad, the experiments
formally ended in 1907 and although Wiley
would eventually be credited as being instrumental
in the first significant step towards making
sure food consumed in the U.S. is reasonably
safe, the contributions of the members of
the Poison Squad have been largely overlooked.
This is largely due to the fact that volunteers
were anonymous, meaning in most cases their
names aren’t known, though their badass
moniker of “The Poison Squad” has certainly
endured.
If you liked this article, you might also
enjoy our new popular podcast, The BrainFood
Show (iTunes, Spotify, Google Play Music,
Feed), as well as:
Why are Kinder Eggs Banned in the United States?
Has Anyone Ever Actually Poisoned Or Put Razor
Blades or Needles in Halloween Candy?
The American Government Once Intentionally
Poisoned Certain Alcohol Supplies, Resulting
in the Death of Over 10,000 American Citizens
The True Story Behind The Appalling Tuskegee
Syphilis Experiment
Why are Crazy People Called “Mad as a Hatter”?
Bonus Fact:
As noted, the Pure Food and Drug Act of 1906,
still left an amazing amount of leeway to
poison people to save a buck without any real
consequences.
This leads us to the Elixir Sulfanilamide
Incident.
In a nutshell, sulfanilamide is actually a
perfectly safe antibiotic when administered
properly, and was used, among other things,
at the time to good effect at treating streptococcal
infections.
However, in an attempt to create a liquid
version of the drug (it normally came in either
powder or tablet form), the lead chemist at
S.E.
Massengill Company, Harold Cole Watkins, mixed
it with diethylene glycol, commonly used today
in antifreeze and as a solvent.
At the time, it was known that diethylene
glycol was highly poisonous to humans (most
notably causing kidney failure), but Watkins
did not know this when he decided to use it
in the company’s elixir.
He chose it owing to how well sulfanilamide
dissolved in the substance and because diethylene
glycol tastes slightly sweet, making it particularly
good for getting children to take their medicine.
In this case, even animal testing would not
have been required to discover the substance
was toxic.
Watkins would have merely needed to do a surface
level look into the compound, with several
previous published studies noting diethylene
glycol, even in relatively small doses, would
cause kidney damage and potentially failure
of said organ.
But no such due-diligence research nor testing
to determine the safety of such an elixir
before putting it on the market was required
at the time.
Blissfully unaware that they were about to
start selling a tasty tonic of death to their
customers, S.E.
Massengill sent out 633 shipments of the elixir
in the autumn of 1937 to pharmacists across
the nation.
It didn’t take long for disturbing reports
to begin coming in, including news of deaths
trickling back to S.E.
Massengill Co, resulting in them issuing telegrams
requesting the elixir be sent back for a full
refund, though not disclosing to pharmacists
the seriousness of the issue if they ignored
the telegram.
This all was capped by a short and truly heart
wrenching letter by one Marie Nidiffer to
President Franklin D. Roosevelt describing
what happened in the days following administering
the drug to her 6 year old daughter, who at
the time was suffering from a sore throat:
The first time I ever had occasion to call
in a doctor for [Joan] and she was given Elixir
of Sulfanilamide.
All that is left to us is the caring for her
little grave.
Even the memory of her is mixed with sorrow
for we can see her little body tossing to
and fro and hear that little voice screaming
with pain and it seems as though it would
drive me insane.
… It is my plea that you will take steps
to prevent such sales of drugs that will take
little lives and leave such suffering behind
and such a bleak outlook on the future as
I have tonight.
As for Dr. Samual Evans Massengill, who owned
S.E.
Massengill Co., he responded to the many dozens
of deaths caused by his company’s negligence
by issuing the following statement:
My chemists and I deeply regret the fatal
results, but there was no error in the manufacture
of the product.
We have been supplying a legitimate professional
demand and no one could have foreseen the
unlooked-for results.
I do not feel that there was any responsibility
on our part…
Needless to say, when all this came to light,
the public were more than a little outraged,
with S.E.
Massengill’s somewhat brazen statement that
his drug company wasn’t responsible for
making sure their products weren’t simply
poison at the recommended dose before selling
them.
To add to the tragedy, it appears Harold Watkins
did not quite have the clear conscience of
Dr. Massengill, with Watkins sadly committing
suicide not long after it came to light that
his error had resulted in the deaths of over
100 people.
In the end, the Elixir Sulfanilamide Incident
was the final straw, spurring an upgraded
to the Pure Food and Drug Act of 1906 in the
form of the 1938 Federal Food, Drug, and Cosmetic
Act to hopefully prevent such a tragedy from
occurring again.
Among other things, the Act required that
for the first time in US history, drug makers
had to demonstrate to the FDA that drugs were
reasonably safe before they could be marketed
to the public, set standards for how different
kinds of food should look and be packaged,
and specified legal maximums for “certain
poisonous substances” commonly added to
food and drink at the time.